cutting our losses that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now it's natural that we as humans often
have a hard time letting go admitting to
ourselves that the path we're on as a
dead end that the goal we said is
unattainable or that the costs of
achieving it are just too high
instinctively we feel like ending
something prematurely
maybe is a sign of weakness that
quitting is for losers
but especially in politics the opposite
is often true
which joe biden is president there are
sadly many areas where america needs to
cut her losses first
we need to cut our losses in ukraine if
you hadn't noticed the ukrainians are
not winning as our own nation is hurting
we've allocated more than 53 billion
dollars in counting in humanitarian
military aid to help them beat back the
russians
but now well here's a headline from
bloomberg
putin may win in ukraine
but the real war is just starting what
and more americans now say russia rather
than ukraine is winning the war too
but despite that biden still thinks that
spending
all that money and time when new mothers
can't get formula and people can't
afford gas is worth it
defending freedom defending democracy
was not going to go without cost for the
american people we were going to have to
pay a price as well
in the cost of military equipment
economic assistance humanitarian relief
i believe then and i believe now
the free world had no choice
america could not stand by
it's time to cut our losses before this
turns into another iraq or afghanistan
where u.s taxpayers are bled dry for
years and years with no victory
europe isn't poning out the way it
should according to the new working
paper by the kiel institute america is
still the biggest overall contributor
with about half of all commitments to
ukraine made by the united states it's
remarkable that the u.s alone has
committed considerably more than all eu
countries combined and whose immediate
neighborhood the war is raging
and by the way sanctions not working we
said they wouldn't they're not in fact
they're making russia even richer the
ruble's rallying and money is pouring in
from china and other nations
russia's oil and ag exports are soaring
oops
second
it's long since time we cut our losses
in china last year our trade deficit
with them was over 350 billion dollars
we know they use slave labor to make
everything from sneakers to computer
chips they flood us with fentanyl
through mexico and they lied about the
origins of covid
so why are we dependent on china for
anything
but biden of course is taking the
opposite lesson here he's poised to lift
the trump-era tariffs that gave us some
leverage against china and save some u.s
manufacturers
scott paul and the washington examiner
writes that allowing an authoritarian
state unfettered access to the u.s
markets is no longer an acceptable
status quo we shouldn't abandon
important trade leverage against the
chinese government to shave a rounding
error off the consumer price index
we need to start decoupling from china
immediately
third
it's time to cut our losses with this
foolish green obsession
the democrats talk about how great
transitions can be painful at times
but what we're seeing under biden is the
transition from prosperity to poverty
from independence to servitude
americans just can't afford two and a
half more years of high prices for gas
for food and more goods
biden meanwhile responds not with more
drilling permits on federal lands but
with gimmicks
by suspending the 18 cent gas tax
federal gas tax for the next 90 days we
can bring down the price of gas and give
families just a little bit of relief the
second action i'm taking is calling on
states to either suspend the state gas
tax as well
or find other ways to deliver some
relief
don't i love the 18 cent thing behind
him on the wall what is that then he
tries to shame gas station owners into
losing money for the good of the country
my message is simple
to the companies running gas stations
and setting those prices at the pump
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump
do it now
do it today
that's a weird voice he uses
does he not realize that most gas
stations are small businesses a lot of
them are mom and pops they're not owned
by big oil joe
is he stupid or is he just playing
stupid at this point sometimes it's
really hard to tell i don't know
but then again the press thinks that we
all complain too much
there's a great deal of americans where
it is uncomfortable that they're
spending more but they are not going to
go under yeah it's costing you more for
gas but guess what you're still going to
take that holiday that fourth of july
vacation you could still eat out so i'm
going to need you to calm down and back
off because it feeds into this fear and
then this fear feeds into people making
decisions that creates the very thing
that they're fearful of and if you're in
that category
calm down
yeah she's an actual journalist for the
washington post
fourth we also need to cut our losses in
this wokefied military
things are so bad with race and sexual
indoctrination among our soldiers that
even west point is losing its allure
courtesy of judicial watch we see the
academy's training materials they
include these gems in order to
understand racial inequality in slavery
it is first necessary to address
whiteness one slide reads it goes on to
say that whiteness is a location of
structural advantage
of race privilege
now
do you all realize that none of this
gets funded without republican votes
so it's time to put our money where our
miles are and say no cutting our losses
means reforming our military back to its
original purpose and role as a fighting
force
fifth
it's time to cut our losses with all
things covet
if we're up to biden the government
would borrow hundreds of billions of
dollars more for testing we don't need
and vaccines for infants and toddlers
that most parents don't want
just a month into his presidency though
the president was talking a very good
game
i want you to know that once we beat the
covert
we're going to do everything we can to
end cancer as we know it
but now 18 months later he's looking for
more money kovid's still circulating and
he made an ominous reference
we do need more money but we don't just
need more money for vaccines for
children eventually we need more money
to plan for the second pandemic there's
going to be another pandemic we have to
think ahead
i'm going to say this in a way that
biden fans can understand
it's about control kids not the virus
this is crazy now when the gop takes
congress it needs to turn off the money
spigot here and defund any remaining vax
mandates especially the push for vaxing
small children
the entire covet industrial complex
needs to be investigated from the nih to
fauci and the niad
because americans need to know whether
our scientists have been compromised by
grants from big pharma or by their
relationships with china
six we need to cut our losses on crime
by defeating the liberal das wreaking
havoc across america
and i was thinking if san francisco can
boot the soros funded bomb so can other
cities
so it's time for billionaires who are
sane to fund new campaigns to oust all
the left-wing nuts who've eliminated
cash bail and generally made our streets
more dangerous
this is just a matter of life and death
at this point
and seven we need to cut our losses with
the gop establishment oh yes
those dinosaurs lumbering around more
interested in doing deals with biden and
staying true to the
constitution last year they signed on to
an idiotic infrastructure bill and now
many of the same senators are signing on
to a gun control bill
14 republicans in all led by john cornyn
of texas they're giving biden a victory
and infringing on the rights of
law-abiding americans the legislation is
80 pages long and last night a vote was
called just hours after the text was
even released
it's a complete travesty
it's one more step on the road to a gun
ban more on this later
and finally
americans need to cut their losses with
the party in power
you know democrats are in charge and
they not vladimir putin are destroying
almost everything we love today
americans are getting poorer by the day
as the cost of everything is going up
oh except for one thing
the dnc has slashed the price of a
kamala harris photo op from 15 000
five thousand what a bargain
but when america is hurting
when our people are hurting when
policies and plans aren't panning out
it's time to switch gears
the swamp here in dc is home to many
varieties of swamp monsters sleazy
lobbyists feckless politicians and fat
cat consultants
it's time to cut our losses and cut them
all loose
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else